one thing that I think makes men amazing
and awesome is how funny they are and
there is a reason that we have phrases
like locker room talk men will just be
so blunt and just roast the [__] out of
each other and um recently that we have
a new UFC middleweight champ um Sean
Strickland he just won um and it's we
did a video like a month ago I think
it's coming out in the next like couple
weeks but yeah he just he just had a
really awesome upset where he he want I
don't know much about the UFC guys but
he he won and basically though
um this was so it was so inspirational
because literally everybody thought he
was gonna lose
um and yeah and then he came out on top
and now it's so funny because all these
clips of him are just going viral like
this man is the most unfiltered dude on
the internet so let's play the clips
every white person I've ever met when I
was a kid and I would you know draw
swash cut my arm they would be like [__]
you nah man I want to [__] you know
try to kill him man and get paid you
were training with him so does that make
you his
[__] [__] I I've never smacked a
woman but you're about to call me would
you like to learn some Chinese dude
Nihao what was that way what am I saying
what am I saying
hello meow
I feel like I should already sir how do
I say work harder child
so when I started my clothing when I
start my clothing company and I opened
up a couple sweatshops how do I how do I
get to the meat and potatoes of work
harder no food for you till you finish
all right next question do you believe
fat shaming is okay if the person you're
fat shaming is someone you love
I think fat Shaman is always okay I
there's nothing worse than being next to
a fat smelly [__] and the most
human thing you could do is telling a
fat smelly [__] to put down the
fork well where do you think a win over
a boost would take you so here's the
thing guys I'm gonna speak straight with
you I always do I'm honest I try to be
you know unless I'm trying to sleep with
you well I don't have to put big black
things in my face like this but we'll
make it happen I feel like you're used
to it I think you're used to it anyways
how do you think she got the Jon Jones
interview
[Music]
and honestly okay so we have all of
these two would like he's just like the
most unfiltered man on the planet it's
so funny seeing all of the red pill like
all over his stuff because I saw his
women um shouldn't vote rant like I
don't know a month or two ago and I just
thought it was hilarious
um so I I've been on I've been on this
wave but it's it's funny to see everyone
at the red pill like pick up on him
um okay so he says could you picture
being Jill Biden at a family dinner and
he said well Hunter I see you've stopped
effing your brother's wife I'm really
proud of you also that sex tape you made
was very impressive anyways my rent is
coming any word on that payment from
China or Ukraine no and this is the
thing like there's so many times where
men will lose their jobs for talking
like this and what I love about the UFC
is it's like one of the few places where
guys can just talk
unfiltered without I mean they don't
seem to have the same consequence as
someone would have in Corporate America
you know I mean what happened to The
Wolf of Wall Street type environment
there's a reason guys loved that movie
now I'm not saying I know they had like
hookers at work that's probably a bit a
bit far you know but but and that but
that's what I mean where I say like the
the workplace used to be a truly
masculine place
um where people could talk freely and I
just think a lot of times women get in
here and we tell men how to talk and I'm
just really sick of I'm really sick of
seeing it in 2023 I mean we just whine
whine whine